for an unfiltered analysis of the 2020
presidential race and many more topics
we turn now to syndicated radio talk
show host Rush Limbaugh he joins us live
from his studio
Dean Rush welcome to special report it's
great to be here this is a milestone for
me my first ever appearance on your
program and I'm honored to be here oh
thanks you know it's been a couple days
since the Attorney General wrote that
four-page letter describing his
conclusions from the malla report what's
your assessment of the fallout since
that time I think all the fallouts a
bunch of distraction aliy we got to keep
track of exactly what this was breath
there was zero collusion there was no
collusion there was never any evidence
of any collusion between Trump or his
campaign and Russia zilch zero nada they
began an investigation based on a phony
dossier that was created excuse me and
written by my associates of Hillary
Clinton it was opposition research this
is outrageous what has happened here
there needs to be an investigation into
this there needs to be accountability
for everybody who participated in this
from people high up in the Obama
administration all the way down and
including most of the mainstream media
it has been two years that we have been
distracted this country has been placed
through it's going through hell here the
people of this country were told their
president was a traitor they were
assured their president had colluded had
stolen the election none of it happened
in the special council has known there
was no collusion since before the
investigation began there has never been
any evidence of it I don't care what
Schiff says and our Comey says or any of
the rest of them this whole thing is a
manufactured coup because these people
could not accept the results of the 2016
election and they're continuing it Brent
they are continuing to try yo gets whoa
well and you're looking at shift their
their conduct illustrates that this is
an ongoing political project to get rid
of Donald Trump it has nothing to do
with finding out if a foreign power had
anything to do with our elections
because a foreign power did not
well you mentioned
congressman Schiff and Congressman slaw
well both saying they want to see all
300 plus pages at the motor report and
they're saying there could be more in
there take a listen to them I think he
acts on Russia's behalf and he puts
Russia's interests ahead too often of
America's interests there's ample
evidence of occlusion in plain sight and
that is true there's a difference
between there being evidence of
occlusion and proof beyond a reasonable
doubt of a crime what do you think of
that there is no evidence of collusion
the man is lying through his teeth this
is exactly what I mean by they trying to
keep this alive
I heard today in the New York Times hey
guess what the mullah reports actually
300 pages and Barr summarized it in four
there must be something at the gate are
they serious about this they really
Pelosi and the rest want us to believe
that bar is lying about what's in this
report that there is evidence of
collusion in this report if that's true
what must they think of our what must
they and where is Muller saying hey wait
a minute Barr is lying about this I
found collusion I found obstruction it's
in my report Muller isn't saying that
neither are the 19 pro-hillary
investigators on his staff saying that
this is a Brent it's just continuing
slow well and Schiff are lying to the
American people because they can't give
it up it is outrageous and some of these
people need to be held account I hope
the president calls a special council to
look into this because the American
people deserve to know how they have
been manipulated how they have been used
they deserve to know what the Democrat
Party and the American left descending
from the Obama administration attempted
to pull off here and it better never
ever happened again this is one this is
probably the biggest political scandal
certainly of our lifetimes and maybe
even longer the president called in was
Sean Hannity and talked about the FISA
documents that started this
investigation here's what he said I have
plans to deep laugh safai and release I
have plans to absolutely release but I
have some very talented people working
for me lawyers I thought it would be
better if we held it to the end no but
at the right time
will be absolutely released again I did
the right thing by not doing it so far
so do you think you're calling for a
special counsel I mean is there special
counsel kind of overload with the
American people what was that is there a
special counsel what for the American
people
overload are there people we gonna get
to I you know I understand another two
years can the American people put up
with it I asked I asked myself the same
question but the president is right if
he would declassify you know what I wish
they would do declassify everything to
do with FISA and everything to do with
this investigation of then announce that
he's closing the border and shutting
down immigration till we can get a
handle on it and then pardon everybody
that has been abused by this unnecessary
investigation you mentioned FISA for
crying out loud were the FISA judges on
this a phony opposition research
document called a dossier was used four
times there's not a shred of evidence in
it none of it has been corroborated and
they used it to get warrants to spy on
the opposing presidential campaign four
different times and there's never been
any evidence of collusion I keep
repeating this because it's it's it's
I'm adamant the American people
understand exactly what this happened
here this is a huge hoax that has been
perpetrated that makes every other hoax
in our lifetime pale in comparison not a
shred of evidence that FISA warrant all
four of them were based on absolute lies
put together by Hillary Clinton's
campaign team and they and they and they
what did the FISA Court to get warrants
to spy on people with it it's outrageous
to me so you Sean Hannity Laura Ingraham
Mark Levin a small group believed that
from day one and we could take you back
to two years ago you were saying roughly
the same thing one of the reasons we
wanted to talk to you you know when you
go around the country rush there are
some people who support the president's
actions what his administration is doing
but they don't like the way he tweets or
talks or attacks his opponents what do
you say to those people I say he should
continue tweeting look at the forces
that are aligned and arrayed against him
breath he has what everybody thinks is a
media we don't have a media in this
country there isn't a group of people
going out and reporting the news and
then telling us what happened that we
didn't know about we have Democrat
activists we have left-wing hacks that
are disguised as journalists that are
helping propel the effort to get rid of
Donald Trump the only pushback he has
the only opportunity to get his side of
things out is via his tweets so I hope
he keeps plus they're funny they're
great I love having them to talk about
and I hope he keeps it up it does look
I'm a trump supporter unabashed and I
love them it doesn't bother me in any
way shape matters for me I have some
people telling me you know you want to
tell him to stop tweeting I wouldn't I
want him to keep doing it